the Jaguars rookie running back Leonard
fournette joining us on the program
Leonard thanks for joining us how are
you today I'm good man thanks for having
me uh do you have a nickname yeah some
people call me booger call me seven well
I'm gonna call me button so that's - my
name is I go ba wait button yeah Y
button my grandmother gave me that name
when I was young is my nose smaller like
a blood but you cute as a button
yeah get out of the button I don't think
that's intimidating though as you're
running through defense I kind of do the
name but I'm everybody steals
cause--'cause minute so there's no big
thing I heard you got a new hobby got
new hobby
yeah Golf are you playing golf yeah I
try but uh you know not taking some some
time I'm not really good at it right now
but uh I've gotten better I can say that
okay it's gonna be tougher than football
just to let you know Leonard oh yeah
most definitely I'm thinking of the
first time I tried it how do you feel
after yesterday's game physically man
just came in got some work on my body
you know that's the biggest part right
now is just taking care of our bodies
you know knowing that we have another
solution mashup coming up this week and
I just taken cow bodies and getting
getting it done
did you actually wave to one of the
Steelers to kind of come on and hit you
Mike Mitchell yeah yeah Mike was going
that is the whole game you know so uh it
was uh it was it was it was it was a bit
matchup man you know I can say honestly
he made me better started that duration
of the game and uh we came out
victorious that was a good nice tackle
that I mean he hit you you said come get
some and he came and got some yeah but
you're used to can you get the feeling
that there are guys who don't want to
tackle you well I mean yeah most
definitely man I mean sometimes you have
to make your presence felt on the first
first run that you get and that kind of
spreads it out throughout the whole
defense and I see what you're working
with me but not just me I mean my line
does a great job you know
the main thing we focus on is being
physical so I mean without those guys
they stop with them and then becomes us
so I mean it starts with Emily and we
have to finish it finish it as running
back but also wasn't at the Auburn game
where the announcer said it looked like
they didn't want to tackle you oh yeah
did they not want to tackle you I mean I
don't know and compete each and every
time I get the ball in my hands
did you watch film already no actually
watch film today in a victory of Monday
we come and watch film so we're gonna
watch of the day and see what coach our
clothes have to say all right take us
through the 19 yard touchdown run
I mean uh man I'm the Arab I was in the
box
we ran the ball he did a great job with
his pulling I mean nobody was there
and uh I kept hearing when I went our
coach kept saying far down on the
sideline fall down I mean nobody ya fall
down you know it's a situation of a plan
that we always go over as a whole but I
mean nobody's there so I just kept on
running wait why did he want you to fall
down I mean I don't know say the truth
but uh my mind no bodily today and I
know nobody was gonna catch me so I just
kept running did you look at the
jumbotron did you watch yourself on the
big screen as you're running running
down the field closing in on me or
anything oh yeah definitely I love that
that's good
but maybe maybe your coach is saying
fall down so you don't run up the score
it's not the NFL right Leonard fournette
the Jags rookie running back button is
what they like to call him I like to
call him seven joining us Dan Patrick
show the come to welcome to the NFL
moment did you have one of those hits
where you went okay it's a little
different than LSU I mean he's never get
me playing money play against tremendous
guys with different talents and uh also
work hard so I mean is every every
every game we playing like I might get a
lick you know they wake me up you know
just saying I'm an NFL you know some
some some days on Sundays I wake up man
I still can't believe I'm in the NFL you
know and I think that's one of the ones
still one of the most craziest things to
me that I'm playing an affair each and
every Sunday did you have you bought
anything interesting
no I haven't brought everybody nothing
interesting
so you but so you saving your money
you're not doing anything crazy yeah oh
yeah I have to all right that's good hey
congrats so far the Rams are gonna be
ready for you just to let you know yeah
most definitely
big guys out there no can't wait about
that me that would uh Todd Gurley man
you know he's a rogue nation guy like me
so he's waiting on God and hopefully
while Jerry is with him who did you
idolize growing up who was yeah posters
on your wall no no I wasn't really no
big football fan you know and I didn't
watch it at all would you want without
now saw playing football and stuff and I
didn't really focus on football that
much so you didn't have somebody that
you wanted to emulate as a running back
no no sir not not in high school as a
kid not even in college well now they're
trying to emulate you hey congrats so
far and first place Jaguars
he's Leonard fournette number seven or
you can call him button as well Thank
You Leonard good to talk to you again
yes hey thanks for having that's Leonard
fournette very punctual as well called
in early button the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience